the greatest public speakers became
great because they eventually found
their voice not somebody else's voice
but their voice let me explain to you
what I mean by that
have you ever sat in a room where
somebody is speaking and it's so awkward
or uncomfortable that you truly cannot
wait to leave the room like you are
going lower in your chair and you're
trying to hide and maybe putting the hat
you just don't want to be seen and you
feeling sorry for the speaker why is
that here's why it's because a person is
trying to speak like somebody else and
they're not that person they're not like
the other person the best way to give
you the analogy that'll make sense to
you is this think about music how many
different music genres are there okay
think about all the different music
genres that we have now I want you to
visualize this take Tupac imagine Tupac
singing country music can you see it you
can't see I can't see it like you
imagine DJ all I need in life for sin as
me
I just doesn't make any sounds I can't
even do it right now all I need in this
life it's his song right now take Blake
what's his last name Shelton now imagine
Blake Shelton we ask him to think
hip-hop can you see it can you truly see
it can you see Blake Shelton singing
hip-hop I can't see it because that's
not his voice and that's not to parks
voice and you need to find your voice
and when people ask me this most random
question pad I want to be a better
public speaker what can I do find your
voice stop trying to be somebody else's
voice what does that even mean so
finally instead of asks answering
hundreds of emails that I get on this I
just thought I'm gonna make a video
again keep in mind every single video I
make I make because of the question I
get asked so many times I eventually
make a video about it so let's get right
into it I got some points that I'll give
you about speaking 16 of them but before
getting into it I first want to tell you
multiple styles of public speakers and
you need to ask yourself which one is
you and identify with that speaker then
go study speakers that have that style
because that's your style if that made
any sense so let's get right into it
first one is the mentor advisor so who
is the mentor
this could be a Tony Robbins type of a
speaker when he speaks he can't help
himself by give you advice he can't help
himself by give you direction he can't
help himself but lead you right I tell
you here's what I would do in a 10 day
up because that's their style so mentor
advisor high high energy that's a Tony
Robbins if you got the charm and the
humor this could be a Ronald Reagan when
he would speak I can't think of a time
he spoke where he didn't have a joke to
say it was always humor
charm smile his pacing was slow he
wasn't the fast talking guy Tony Robbins
can run laps around Ronald Reagan when
it comes on to speaking because Tony can
say thousand words in 30 seconds and
Reagan is just on number 68
for instance I'm giving you an example
here so charm humor maybe a Ronald
Reagan with his sensor so you may say I
have a great sense of humor use it I
people have told me I'm charming use it
go study Ronald Reagan somebody may say
well I'm more like bold you know I just
kind of want to tell people and tell him
off but I know what I'm talking about
well then that's Gary Vaynerchuk he is
extremely bold he'll get up and curse
the entire audience out but he knows
what he's talking about so bold yet
credible now some people say I don't
like Gary style he's not talking to you
he's got his own style but he's bold yet
credible okay some people don't like
Reagan I know people that say I can't
even listen to 20 Robbins's voice I
can't listen to Tony Robbins he's not
speaking to you
you're not the audience okay the next
locker room talk you may say you know
what I'm more like the locker room type
of top type of guy I like to sit down
and tell people what they need to be
doing great you may study Mike Ditka
Mike Ditka was a locker room talk type
of a guy he sat there and told people
here's what you need to do you need to
get and he was locker room fired
everybody I've ticked them off and a
boom they're ready to go to war that's
Mike Ditka go study Mike Ditka coach of
Chicago Bears a lot of people don't like
him but he did very well as a player and
as a football coach another one may be
commanding firm like a general lesk like
you know Netanyahu Prime Minister
Netanyahu from Israel just recently gave
a talk to a United Nations I believe and
he gave a talk
that I recommend you listening to
because he was firm slow bold respected
everybody opened it up with respect to
everybody but he made his point
commanding firm general esque that may
be you many people don't like his style
but you may speak like that you need to
be true to your voice the next one is
crusade you may be a crusader and nobody
really understand what I mean your
Crusader why do you always talk about
correcting and injustice
maybe you need to study you know MLK
Billy Graham Malcolm X by the way
conflicting beliefs Malcolm X and MLK
milligram they're not the same beliefs
but they had a crusade it was a cause
right so you know that's the category I
would be studying if that's your style
of speaking you may say that's not me
then keep continuing on the next people
storyteller imagination Steve Jobs Steve
Jobs does not speak like Ronald Reagan
or speak like you know a Tony Robbins or
Gary or any of these other guys but when
Steve Jobs spoke people listened because
it was an incredible storyteller and it
was an unbelievable guy at making you
and I imagine things that weren't
possible can you imagine if you and I
you know the Walkman and all of a sudden
he takes out the you know iPod oh my
gosh it's an iPod can you imagine having
a computer within your hands and he
takes at the iPad do you remember the
first time you not found out about iPad
everybody wanted one remember the first
time somebody had an iPod how did you
and I read how many songs 5,000 songs
that's like me having 5,000 CD do my
imagination can you imagine if you have
an iPod and iPod touch and iPad all
together call the iPhone okay
I mean it's imagination so maybe your
gift is imagination
the other one is presence what's
presence Oprah Winfrey when she enters a
room presence entered there's presence
so her speaking style maybe presence it
maybe curiosity it may be questions that
she does but that's your style next one
maybe arrogant you know what arrogant is
this is not who you want to be this is
somebody that acts like you know what
they're talking about yet everybody's
thinking they were full Kanye West and
there are many people like that out
there
but he has a lot of people may say party
makes a lot of people follow him that's
great a lot of people follow many
different people
different reasons if that's your style
where you want to convince people that
you know what you're talking about you
don't that's a snob
I just don't recommend that style the
next one is sales somebody that's an
incredible salesman incredible salesman
maybe Warren Buffett I mean Warren
Buffett can sell you you can sit with
Warren Buffett and he can convince you
to drink eight cans of coke for the rest
of your life and you would do it
starting tomorrow you would say hey can
we get a case of Coca Cola because every
day Warren Buffett lives 88 years I need
to drink a tentacle and you would drink
it because he is a Salesman he can't
help himself but sell everywhere he goes
he sells Geico Cadillac dealerships
furniture he just wants to sell and he's
a great salesman if that's you that's
the style listen to Warren Buffett talk
you'll know exactly what I'm talking
about the Nexus seductive
maybe you're the seductive type of
speaker maybe you speak any seduced
people maybe you have your own charming
seductive way well maybe you need to
study JFK need to study Bill Clinton
they were some of the most seductive
speakers of all time Bill Clinton could
give you talk look at you and say
something you would say I have no idea
if he's telling the truth but man I
believe them it's like you're being you
know would he call that thing when
people would hypnotize you you're
seduced you're in a whole different land
that's a seductive speaker right then
you have the technical speaker very very
detailed technical you know like if you
ask a watch some of Elan musk stalks
you'll see it's such a technical speech
when he speaks it's not very much but
it's all technical details that he gets
into and a whole different style of
speaking then he have inspirational
what's an inspirational speaker
inspirational speaker could be Barack
Obama he is inspirational he sells you
to dream like we are going somewhere
because he's an inspirational speaker
and he doesn't do it with a million mile
a minute
very da-da-da-da-da and not that at all
I'm Papa Papa Bob it's just music to
what he does it is just for when when he
does it and he moves you right then we
have philosophical philosophical could
be who that could be
Phil Jackson he makes you question
things you'll talk to Phil
accent and he'll make you question
things he says so hey Phil why did you
do that that that that time he says why
do you think I did that that that that
and why do you think such and such did
this this this this this seem like but I
didn't ask you that question
but I want that answer then you give the
answer oh so it's the speaker that makes
you consciously go out oh now it makes
sense
philosophical speaker maybe that's here
maybe you study Marcus Aurelius maybe
you studied all the different religions
all the different faiths maybe you've
studied every single philosophy from
stoicism to cynicism to every one of
them you've studied so your
philosophical topic that you'd like to
question things
great that's your style and then there's
fear type of leaders people put the fear
into everybody and people perform what's
fear Bobby Knight
Pat Riley I mean I can give you a list
of names there these are fear go study
Bobby Knight go study Pat Riley but Pat
Riley was like a gangster mafia type of
a coach in the NBA right that's who he
was and people would just they wanted to
play for this guy
because he just knew how to get people
to get a light and then BOOM we're gonna
beat the other guy and people believed
it and they did I think he's got five
championships as a coach and obviously
he's got three of them as a general
manager president with what he called it
with Miami's done a fantastic job
probably the best GM's if it wasn't for
him and Dwayne Wade he's probably LeBron
James would probably not go to Miami so
but that's his style by the way just so
you know many of you admire at least two
or three of the people I just mentioned
right now but I'm guarantee if I ask you
right now comment on the bottom and post
the one you like the most out of
everybody I said our promise is not all
going to be the same you'll see some of
you guys are gonna say who is Netanyahu
but some of you got to say man that
y'all was amazing Steve Jobs my favorite
mine is Barack Obama but it's going to
be different it doesn't matter it's your
voice what's your voice find your voice
and don't try to be anybody else when
you're speaking now there are some areas
that you can figure out ways to become
better tactfully or skillset I'm going
to do my best to try to give you some
skill sets but there's a whole technical
side to speaking how big is the stage do
you walk is it a podium is the mic over
here do you hold the mic is it a
wireless mic you know if the type of
wireless mic is a tied here can you walk
around do you need to make sure the
speakers on this side where you go
don't make that sound that sound you
need to know your real estate there are
things that you need to end up but
that's technical stuff forget about the
technical stuff technical stuff happens
after you're given thousands of talks
you'll realize about the different AV
systems lighting where do you need to
stand to be the lighting perfect in your
face that's purely technical I'm giving
you basic how - I'm not getting
technical here I'm giving you basic how
to when it comes on to speaking and
hopefully some of these things can help
you out listen for me when I think about
a great public speaker this is my number
one let me tell you what my number one
is if I can go and hear somebody speak
ok whoever it is any one of these guys
if I can go and hear somebody speak and
the entire time
Michael and Joe you still go with us
about cross marks ok the entire time
when this person is speaking if I go
hear somebody speak and I feel like he'd
the audience could have thousands of
people in the room but I feel like it's
just me and this person speaking that to
me is a great speaker if it's just you
and I that to me is a great speaker if I
get lost during his speech and I forget
everybody else is in the room I forget
I'm watching a video I forget I'm
watching a movie I'm watching like for
instance when when gladiator when
Gladius Maximus Russell Crowe gives that
one speech no one exists and you're just
in the movie you are there or when you
know a Braveheart what's his name
Braveheart
William or Mel Gibson gets up and he
gives that one speech with the whole you
know William Wallace when he gives that
speech I mean you watch that no one
exists right or you hear Denzel
Washington give a talk in John Q my son
is not gonna I'm not going to bury my
son my son's going to bury who me
you're lost it's bone it's one person
right if a speaker knows how to do that
they all do it in their own separate
ways that to me is a great speaker okay
so if you can captivate me to the pond
where I think is just you and I as if
you're not having a cup of coffee over
having lunch and I'm simply listening to
you speak you've already won you don't
even need to watch the rest of the video
turn off the video and skip to another
video you don't even watch anything else
if you learn how to do that the rest is
over with okay rest is over with because
all the other stuff you'll pick up I
doing so many times of speaking you'll
get better at it the next thing number
two number two to me is somebody that is
very good at making their point by
telling stories sometime when I get
asked to speak for three hours and they
want to do Q&A that's a different talk
than it is from an hour to just give a
presentation than it is from hey can you
give a ten minute talk here then a five
minute talk if I'm asked to talk five
minutes on TV or on whatever it is that
I'm speaking for five minutes
I'm here's a point here's a story done
let me tell you bout what's going on
over here here's the conditions that
we're looking at right now that I
thought that uh here's what I think we
need to consider change into and here's
what I believe will be the solution let
me tell you why I believe this I
remember when it was 1992 and both story
okay story so get into your story when
you want it to make your point tell
story somebody who is very good at
making stories and figuring out ways for
me to take a metaphor or an analogy that
I can excited MX that makes sense I get
it I got it I respond to that and most
people respond to that as well if you're
telling your story number three make
your case so look at speaking as these
three different points right these three
different points down so you can count
on some what I'm saying with this first
state your facts for instance
unemployment right now in America is
nine point two percent it's not I'm just
making it up okay unemployment right now
is Mountain America's and nine point two
percent
here's what I think we need to do we
need to get people going back to jobs by
Lauren to taxes okay all we need to
raise the taxes and tax the top one
percent and make the pay the bottom you
know eighty percent that's what we need
to do and if we do this I believe
unemployment is going to go from nine
point two percent to four point three
percent take that three format and go
through it state of fact make your
argument why did you join you stake your
facts make your argument why did she
join you just follow that format written
by the way practice this and with any
case any are it doesn't matter what it
is take anything follow that three step
and you look what happen then you'll get
judged based on how well you do in the
middle so I think about it this is when
you speak like then you're an attorney
you're going to get judged based on the
middle okay by the way this could happen
with family as well your sinner saying
listen let's take the facts you're great
you're at your score like that should I
talking to your kid
here's your great I'm senior grades and
let me explain to what I think this is
taking place I think one of the reason
is because you're doing this this this
is this is it and I think if you do this
here's what could happen and you always
wanted to play baseball for Pepperdine
University because that's the way you
want to go into Major League Baseball
this is your opportunity so I think if
you do this here's a fact we can get
some scholarship you can go play for
Pepperdine and maybe one day play for
the Major League Baseball what do you
say what do you think about that three
step process okay those two restate your
facts make your argument and why should
the why should they should join you if
they do what's going to happen okay so
you're speaking like an attorney because
you're making a case next next point
number four is if you are a first-time
speaker or you've only speaking a
handful of times typically things that
will make you sound like you know what
you do you've done this a few times
before let's just say you got three
points you're making to each point add a
quote to it Winston Churchill once said
history will be kind to me for I intend
to write it I think we need to focus on
writing our own history by writing out
our goals and commitments on what we
want to do okay great okay you know you
know imagination is more important
knowledge was said by Einstein I think
sometimes we spend too much time on the
facts and today we need to spend some
time on our dreams that's your point
number two dreams but point
quote point quote point quote especially
if you're newer the more you speak the
more you read the more quotes you have
in your repertoire they're going to come
out just purely by you haven't done
these talks so many times so add a quote
that'll make it a lot easier for you
number 5 connect with the audience how
do you connect with the audience look at
them and make eye contact with them make
eye contact with them and choose a
handful of people that are engaged the
most and make eye contact with them
don't worry about the guy yawn it don't
even look at the person that's young it
they're going to they're going to
confuse you look at the person that is
fully engaged and make eye contact keep
going back boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom especially when you're newer
make eye contact and by the way one
thing you don't want to do is just stay
on one person a lot of times amateurs
stay on one person and that person is
very uncomfortable and everybody else is
saying hey do you want to talk to us as
well so you got to make sure you're
dancing see this is a dance hey dancing
with everybody ok I contact going
everywhere next is you know I said it
already don't try to sound like others
pick your voice and stick to that voice
on who you are you can many times ask
somebody on your style of speaking and
if you made a list of these if you made
a list of these and you put them out
there someone's going to say you know
what I see you more as it's up this type
of a speaker great then take that and
ask yourself which one you are and work
on that type of the speaking but make
sure you're staying true to your to your
own voice 7 preparation simple as that
when I first started speaking initially
and I was very nervous about speaking
the first time I spoke I spoke at a I'll
take exactly the first time I spoke I
spoke at a Denny's in Compton okay out
of all the places I spoke at a Denny's
at the Compton and it was a last-minute
the speaker just asked me to come up and
I was not prepared to speak I've never
spoken in my life I'm a military guy but
he asked me to come up and I went up and
I couldn't wait to sit down it was a
worst talk I ever give in my life I was
nervous like you wouldn't believe and
then from there I started doing more of
them and then eventually there was a
system to it but I realized if I'm not a
pro because I haven't given thousands of
talks in my life I need to make sure I
over
pear so I focused on preparation point
like the easiest way sometimes people
write to write their entire speech
that's okay
I don't recommend it because I don't
listen when somebody writes their entire
speech so I'm telling you as a listener
I will not listen to your speech if you
just write the whole script and you're
going through it you're going to have a
hard time gaining my attention if you
just you know people will do one of
these things they'll say you know what
I'm so nervous I'm just going to read my
speech okay so hi thank you so much for
giving me this time mr. Johnson this is
an honor to be you lost me already I'm
gone so I suggest take a card make five
bullet points and under each bullet
points make three points if you need to
make it and add a story to it so if you
put Volkswagen story and that you know
what Volkswagen stories get into it you
may put you know a you know a Hugo Boss
story this is a suit one time you had an
ad ripped and you went on to an
appointment and they laughed at you and
you realize before they even laugh at
you we're going to tell them I'm so
sorry when I was coming and I hit the
door and I cut my pants so my apologies
for these pants I'll make sure I get a
fix on the next time we meet together ha
ha ha let's get into the meeting for
instance but that's your story
okay so the more prepared you are as a
rookie the better it is even as a
veteran but as a rookie even more
important okay next 8 what is your
outcome what is truly your outcome of
giving this talk what is your ideal
outcome of what you want to start seeing
happen with this talk what is the action
item what do you want him to take action
with truly is it to buy is it to
register is it to sign up is it to
subscribe is it to move is it to be
somewhere else is it to attend enough so
what is your outcome what is truly your
outcome of this talk you're given be
very specific of your outcome and make
sure you're staying true to your outcome
sometimes you're given so much you like
I'm giving doing a such a good job and
you finish it like I don't even hit my
outcome
what is your outcome go after your
outcome okay next know your audience
very important to know who you're
speaking to so how old are they or
income what are they were they from why
they're there to hear you do they care
to hear you do they like you do they
even know who you are you know do they
pay attention are they younger if
they're younger
how much of an attention span do they
have I've spoken in front of prisons
I've spoken in front of you know people
who just got out of prison I've spoken
in front of billionaires I've spoken in
front of millionaires I've spoken in
front of clergy I've spoken in front of
atheism I've spoken in front of a debate
politically so who is your audience that
you're speaking to then you'll know how
to make the adjustments based on the
audience you're speaking to mix action
items put your action items similar to
your outcome but action items my action
items are first I want to do this cue I
wanted to do that three I would like
them to do this so at the end give your
action items point number one here's
what I want you to do I want you to go
and do that I thought that I'll go to
the website and register number two I
need you to send me an email right now
take out your phones and send me an
email and tell me what is the thing that
you're going to be changing about
yourself today
whatever it is and three the pamphlet I
have underneath you when you're leaving
I need you to come to my booth or when
you're leaving I need you to go by this
book doesn't matter give your action
items when you're leaving okay eleven
typically it's good to come and meet the
audience before
shake hands greet talk to people let
them get to know you get to know them
there's some kind of a relationship
going on and when you're speaking from
stage you can typically identify one of
the people you spoke then that helps yet
a lot when you're speaking edify the
venue and the inviter and the
organization that brought you up for
instance if you're speaking at someone
they asked you to speak don't right off
the bat go in and say thank you so much
for this it's too you know you're too
black and white get into it and break
the ice and talking and five minutes
into and say hey by the way thank you
for the invite and then but make sure
you are recognizing the people that gave
you that platform because without that
platform you won't have that platform
the audience you're speaking to so
that's that part and then 13 disturb you
know the greater speakers I know they're
not or disrupt and move people these
guys are big on disturbing great leaders
are phenomenal i disturbing getting
people to move you better believe
Crusades the speakers are very much
about disturbing you know bold yet
credible they're all about disturbing
locker room talk they're about
disturbing commanding they're about
disturbing so figure out a way on how to
disturb and make me move so think about
people that spoke to you how do they
make you move you be that person to your
audience
14 challenge
them there's got to be a challenge I
have a challenge for you here's my
challenge to you my challenge to use to
do this this this there's got to be a
challenge a given to everybody the
greatest talk ever
you give without a challenge at the end
is worthless just so you know if I don't
leave after hearing you speaking I don't
take any action I have any challenge
that I need to be doing your talk was a
waste of time within an hour I'm over it
already
no-one's talking about it but you need
to give me a challenge the best type of
speakers are the ones that I walk away
saying man I feel like I'm not good
enough I gotta improve on this I got to
do this challenge I have a challenge
that you need to impose your challenge
you're gonna give to your audience then
it's 15 rehearse practice your talk
especially if your nor in front of other
people and at last but not least get
your timing right
what is timing when you put your story
here when you disturb when you do this
and timing is a sports is all about
timing okay this is timing okay
football is timing golf is timing this
is a game of timing speaking is also
timing and by the way with timing time
is probably the last thing you're gonna
pick up because it's not going to come
right off the bat you won't get timing
until you give 100 200 300 talk so just
something to be thinking about and the
more you give you'll know what I mean by
the time you can comment on the bottom
and I'll do my best to get back at you
with the comments but timing comes or
later
that doesn't come early on those are
some points I have for you how many of
them was it was just 16 points I got for
you on how to become a better public
speaker but you may want to go back and
look at these and pick and choose who it
is and start studying that person style
of speaking and mainly focus on that
person style of speaking don't try to be
somebody you're not and you'll be amazed
by the type of talks you'll eventually
start giving them by the way keep this
in mind it helps to give a lot of talks
so this is one of the benefits of being
an entrepreneur and being in sales you
have many different opportunities give
talks to your sales organization
sometimes people who are involved in
sales end up becoming great speakers
because they have more opportunities
give talks than somebody who is not so I
highly recommend being involved at some
side some type of a sales organization
sales model where you can constantly be
doing this to see the reaction you're
getting the response you getting from
everybody else so now with that being
said I do not think we have the pillow
here because Paul action matter of fact
it's right here Mike if you can get this
for us hey you
any questions post them on the bottom if
you haven't subscribed yet please be
sure to do so the SUBSCRIBE pillow was
here at Harvard Boston for the last
three four weeks Paul literally just got
back today so make sure to subscribe we
have a very special episode that's
coming in when we cross 100,000 fans
that we're going to need your help
you're going to put a lot of you guys in
the video and I'll tell you how that's
going to be so stay tuned for the email
that's going to go out in a video post
to tell you exactly what we're doing
once we reach 100,000 I think right now
we're at 97 thousand subs or so while
you're watching this video we may
already cross a hundred thousand by the
time some of you watch it so again
subscribe and please if you think this
is a video that's going to help some of
your teammates some of the other people
that you may know in your business in
your company be sure to share this video
as well with everybody else thanks for
watching everybody take care bye